she and I were waiting in line for the
seventh book I mean like 10 minutes
before midnight I just have like this
awful fear because we weren't at the
front of the line but I just had this
awful fear which nobody that had waited
in that line all day nobody would there
would have done this I mean you're
talking about the most die-hard fans
right there I just had this awful fear
of like what if somebody just grabs
their copybook seven lips to the end and
just starts blurting out spoilers this
thought just hits me all at once and I
tell her I was like here take my money
pay for it I'm gonna go wait in the car
I can't get spoiled and she's just like
what wait what and then the people that
we had been standing there talking to
they're like where did he go but you
know what I did not get spoiled I did
not get spoiled